so this week we're also highlighting
ways for you to say to stay
fit we're giving you and your family
some ideas some tips to stay in shape at
home
especially trying to stay out of the
heat hector mejia live this morning
learning from a personal trainer in
north las vegas
hector i see you're out on the street
looking to go for a little bit of a jog
maybe
yeah we actually just came back from
running around the block here in this
neighborhood and it's something so
simple you can do at home here
you can go outside jog around your own
neighborhood and get a small little
workout before you head out to work so
joining us live we have
kiana here to talk to us about a virtual
30-day challenge as we highlight a local
program here
to stay healthy for 2021 good morning to
you good morning
so yeah in our program we focus on
simple exercises
that are easy to do at home we guide you
through the program obviously it's very
guided
we helped you with your form just
teaching you different exercises in a
safe way
and in a safe way we also have an
example here of something you can
actually do
right now at home look at your tv screen
walk us through what we should do or
actually
the proper way to do a squat absolutely
so squats are one of the most
common things that um kind of get you
know a little confusing so you want to
make sure that you have all that weight
in your heels
you want to make sure that your knees
aren't extending past your toes
and you're sitting your butt back like
you're sitting into a chair so it's
perfect to practice like
with a chair on your couch things like
that make it much easier for your form
and what people can learn from you guys
it's really stuff that anyone from
all ages can do absolutely and there are
all types of modifications that you can
do
never be intimidated any exercise that
you do can be
yep any exercise that you do can be
modified if there we go
you can modify it any
[Music]
i mean not like do i really want to wear
some shorts i was like well
i mean i really do want to wear some
shorts but do i really want to expose
the chicken legs
not really but just for the sake of it
i'll go ahead and do it oh it's okay
don't worry about that that's why i'm
here so i can learn not to have the
chicken legs
there you go we'll build on that muscle
no problem and you have some examples
here some before and after pictures of
people who went through the 30 day
challenge
transformation tell us about it
absolutely so we have people who come
into our challenge they
they either stay for 30 days and they
find those results they're looking for
or they stay for longer and we love that
but all of these are 30 day examples
tell us about your passion and what
drives it you know what helping people
really helping people find their
confidence finding
what makes them happy is what just sets
my soul on fire and i love that
and help them get over the chicken legs
of course absolutely
the exercise makes you feel better it
makes you feel stronger it boosts your
confidence
we'll be talking a little bit more about
that in half an hour from now reporting
live hector mejia
and kiana back to you guys in the studio
thank you hector thank you kiana
yeah uh hecarim you seem hung up on the
chicken legs
keana's so kind yes she makes her feel
good about his physique no matter what
she will fix your chicken legs don't
worry it's all good
you know they were doing the the squats
that reminds me uh
before the pandemic we used to have a
morning meetings together here at the
station
and a couple of the people on staff
would do the wall planks
where you're leaning up against the wall
and you do the planks those right
yeah it's a simple way and that's it's
subtle but man does your core catch on
fire with that
just a really cool thing and that's a
good exercise if you're going
skiing because it gets you your plots
really requires your thighs yeah
it's all about finding those little ways
to try and just
get active that's what we're doing all
week here on eight news now is trying to
find ways to
get fit get healthy when you're trying
to stay out of the heat and we're trying
to get back in shape for maybe it looks
like she has a nice cool place to work
out
absolutely a lot of fun up there way up
in north las vegas
good stuff